the NBA season started last night and
Charles Barkley former NBA player who's
now an analyst on TNT and of course
always outspoken he's been making the
rounds on the radio he was on CBS radio
in Philly and had some interesting
comments let's take a listen well
unfortunately as I tell my white friends
we as black people we're never going to
be successful not because of you white
people because of other black people
when you're black you have to deal with
so much crap in your life from other
black people
it's a dirty dark secret I'm glad it's
coming out it comes out every few years
I wrote a big chapter in my book about
it to be honest with you I said who know
where young black kids you know when
they do well in school but the loser of
kids tell them oh you're acting white
the kids who speak intelligently right
they tell them you're acting white so
it's a dirty dark secret in the black
community one of the reason we're never
going to be successful as a whole
because other black people and for some
reason we are brainwashed I think if
you're not a thug or an idiot you're not
black enough if you go to school make
good gray speak intelligent and don't
break the law you not a good black
person and it's a dirty dark secret
Anthony okay so we've heard this kind of
thing from other black people Bill Cosby
has done a bunch on this kind of stuff
now jr. according to my paperwork here
you are black is that is that correct
yeah okay
thank you for my searches correct my
researchers okay very good now as a
black person obviously you represent all
black people and everything you say will
be taken by white people as gospel from
the black community do you agree with
his sentiment do you disagree what's
your basic take on what he's again the
reason why this is always tough is
because you can never do this in black
and white terms this is exactly what
Marco did that's where he runs into
trouble and your research may have made
also told you I experienced this growing
up because you know first of all Charles
its speak intelligently should be the
last one when it comes to words and
getting the language prick
which by the way big deal I don't care
that he say that incorrectly so the
thing is I experienced it growing up I
was at high school where I had black
friends and then there was this divide I
grew up in st. Louis mmm
so I know the Ferguson thing I've
experienced men those cops are that way
and there's no life but anyway st. Louis
was and probably still is a divided city
the black kids that lived in the city we
called him the city kids literally and
they would be bused out through the
desegregation program and when I was one
of the county kids they called us County
brownies the black kids who lived in the
county we're on the white folks so that
so there was I got the oh you think
you're so smart
Oh white boy all that stuff right now
what he's missing somehow I'm not sure
what experiences Berkeley had is that
they don't want you to not succeed but
there's this air sometimes about other
folks they think they're better than the
ones who have less less opportunities
and now our scene is in both ways but
the kids were bussed in or look down
upon his thugs dangerous scary not smart
so when you already have that every day
you sometimes embrace it just to feel a
little bit empowered yeah and at the
other time you come after the people who
you think are looking down on you like
no no you're not gonna look down on me
you think you're so [ __ ] smart so I
think that's where the cinema comes from
and the idea is not to bring down black
folks and so when they would get bad
grades and things like that
it's almost uh yeah whatever dude
because it's embarrassing and when the
kids do get good grades which happens
because kids are kids white kids black
kids Asian kids anybody when they get
good grades they're happy about it so
people are almost surprised when one of
these kids who would dog you out for
getting good grade when they got one
they'd go haha
they would celebrated openly in class
yeah all right okay so you give me a lot
to work with there so first off you know
when we've done topics like this like
Ferguson and this kind of thing I always
say that I often book the show and we
booked the show weeks in advance and we
don't book to topic so occasionally
we'll be talking about something like
Ferguson and I don't have a black
panelist I happen to have a black
panelist today or we'll be talking about
something with some other racial
component and we don't have someone of
that race so before I let you jump in
Hank one other thing to you here can
white people discuss this without if you
hadn't
sitting here and and Hank and Ayane and
another white guy let's say we're
sitting here could we talk about this
without with it being okay talk about it
but by the way I encourage it but the
thing is if you don't have a certain
perspective and it's not to say here
black person talk for me because I don't
know anything but just here maybe give
me your perspective I mean again there's
other things that I don't have the
background on that I don't know anything
about how Asians grew up or how gay
people grew up I don't know any of that
stuff so if I can have my perceptions
and I think I should be allowed to throw
out my ideas and if they're wrong
you can tell me hey you know what that's
wrong and what I shouldn't do which is
what a lot of people do the black folks
is you're just complaining they want to
stop what you should do is listen
finally and the problem again the
beginning of what Barclay said is where
his problem came I told my white friends
wait turn your white friends for house
horrible and stupid like you are and if
you think the black community there's a
bunch of thugs and wants everyone else
to be a bunch of thugs
you should probably address that to the
black community not to your white
friends who have I sounds like has a
propensity to think all they're all
thugs they're all scary I can't believe
he did that so when you you're becoming
that I have this one black friend who
tells me my racism is valid yeah
Berkeley has become that and that's why
that's a bad thing to do all right well
also according to my research here Hank
you are Asian sometimes is that correct
okay yeah and and you're also gay is
that that's correct also nice and
weekends okay so you have you have to
I'll I guess technically Asian is
probably not a minority in the world
right let me yeah don't you get me
started okay do you find this kind of
thing at all in the Asian communities
there is there an element of that like
don't talk about us outside of the
community there I will say in my
experience with the various groups that
I am a member of that you will find
discrimination and segregation within
each of these groups so I I remember you
know in Chinatown a few years ago in New
York we were just walking by the Chinese
market and you know you get the loud
merchants yelling at you trying to hawk
their wares and when I remember my
mother walking by and just muttering low
class yeah right and and so in and
there and that was a you know she she
she there was a little bit of disdain in
the way that she said it and I think
similarily from the merchants and there
will be they're quite aggressive with
whoever comes through because that's
what they do so so that's just an
example about how race doesn't really
matter in that context but it's just
kind of it's my I feel like it's a
classist and a status it's a human thing
you're looking at you like oh those
hoity-toity Asians you're looking at
them or the perceived to be looking at
their divisions within the community
yeah I still say well I'm not that kind
of Asian I'm that kind of black person
yeah we see that all the time we even
see that now I mean this is the this has
been a penultimate year I feel like for
Asian representation in the media with
fresh off the boat coming out as well as
John should being the romantic lead in
selfie the first time I think in I mean
market Rose show was 20 years ago and
Margaret show her show failed not
because it wasn't a great sitcom he was
an okay sitcom but okay so this economy
tit is because she didn't get the
support of the community who thought
that she was too fat and not represented
not funny and he was too edgy also she
tattoos and she was openly by which I
didn't help ABC 20 years exactly and all
that kind of stuff and I tell people so
I tell people are like well I don't
think selfies a great show I said I
don't care come to me agent Asian you
better support this goddamn show you
understand you better tweet about Jon
show you better post about this show
because you know what
not everything Tyler Perry does is
amazing either but guess what those
people come out and they pay that money
they support the hoop and holler and
that's why he and every black person on
his show it still has a job so I don't
care if selfies not the best show that
came out the season you [ __ ] support I
hate to even ask this question
because I don't want the world to be
this way but do you guys think that at
the end of the day still so much of what
goes on in our dialogue in the country
is still about race because even though
we'd all like to believe it's beyond
we're beyond that stuff whenever they
show you a poll and we're gonna do some
stuff on polls a little bit but whenever
they show you a poll is CNN poll pew
poll anything they go white people
eighty percent of white people
because that black me believe this and
you know that it's still so racially
divided and that's box boxes how much of
it do you think is actually true cuz I'd
hate to believe that that's the truth
and I always want to believe that we're
actually voting on principles and and
all that but that it obviously still
exists at some level it affects the way
people approach it you you almost want
to go into like when people answer these
poll questions the answer under that
line of thinking how's this going to
come out you know it's like self
reporting and people say how often do
you do this you don't say it always this
honestly because you like you want to
again you want to represent who they're
dividing us the best one when they do a
poll a poll on racism and they ask
people literally they get to their face
and ask them how racist are you well
generally people are gonna tone down the
racism a little bit I think when the
polar is right for any place how much of
it do you think I I think that this
nation I think many cultural cook many
of our conversations center around race
or have or a racial controversies
inferred I think we had that issue prior
to Obama being president and I think
that has been at the forefront since he
has been office been in office I feel
like what any any from what I've seen
and you know I've I look young but I've
survived a few a few presidencies and I
feel like when it comes to Obama's
articles about Obama there's always this
underlying current of because he's black
or because he's not like her because he
and I feel like he just has to work and
fight that much harder and because of
his presidency that has trickled out in
just so many other areas of our culture
from media from you know finance from
you know all the politics that happen
with Ferguson and stuff like that I mean
I feel it working in entertainment and
I'm sure you do too yeah so alright well
I will end the segment with this just by
saying at Barclays actually I think a
pretty great broadcaster and we mean we
need more people whether you agree with
them or not to say what they think and
then you know we have free speech and
then everyone can fight them on it and
let it go so there you go